So it's early Monday Morning
and I've been wanting to
make a Monday Morning video
for a long time
and finally DRock
we're doing it.
So, real quick.
This is just a rant. Very simple.
And something that
I want you to pass on
or watch every Monday Morning
because the level of
complaining is unacceptable.
Look, what If told you
this was the last
Monday morning of your life?
What if I told you
you die this week?
Would you complain
about your crap job or
that test you don't wanna take?
I doubt lt.
You'd go much
higher level thinking.
Well that's really
what it takes.
It takes understanding that
if you're not pumped right now,
if you're begrudging
what you're about to do,
if you're not looking
forward to it.
Look, I respect praticality.
You gotta through school
because your parents want to.
You gotta pay your rent.
You got student loans. I get it.
But please recognize
the world we're living in.
We're living in a world where
there's so much more opportunity
This internet thing created way
more opportunity for all of us.
Way more.
Look, you might not
even have been alive.
Your mom and dad could
have had sex like 3 min later
and you wouldn't even exist.
And you're complaining.
You could have
ended up being a bus.
A tree.
I just don't get the mentality
of being head down,
sad on a Monday Morning.
I'm gonna make
Monday Morning my bitch.
I'm gonna make you
Saturday, Monday Morning!
That's what I want
do every morning.
And that's what
I want from you.
Please, take a step back and
think about how
awesome it actually is.
And then recognize you can
attack the world in a totally
different way 'cause you were
lucky enough to be
born during this era.
Fuck you, Monday!
(hip hop music)